[Música]
parís museo de offside desde hace 34
años esta antigua estación alberga las
obras maestras más hermosas del siglo 19
su increíble colección atrae cada año a
más de 3 millones de visitantes que hay
que impresionar continuamente esta jaula
de vidrio en medio de los espacios de
exposición atrae miradas intrigadas en
su interior se juega el destino del
remordimientos de badr una obra maestra
que hay que cuidar estas heridas
rasgaduras pero también derrames de un
esmalte muy antiguo alix lavó y cecil
declaró trabajan con dedicación desde
hace cuatro meses para hacer renacer el
lienzo del artista
[Música]
la mano tiembla un poco cuando uno va a
pintar de nuevo una obra como esta no
mejor que no es simple y reversible el
único riesgo que corro es retocar mal
pero podría borrarse y empezar de nuevo
borrarlo y empezar de nuevo el
renacimiento de la obra maestra se ópera
en directo ante los visitantes atónitos
venimos con frecuencia 26 pero jamás
habíamos visto eso
es una muy buena idea hay una especie de
magia de costumbre y uno mira antes
luego después y claro queda más
despejado e iluminado se me ocurrió
iluminar
golpea es uno de los seis conservadores
del museo
una gran parte de su misión transcurre
tras bambalinas en las reservas para
renovar la colección presentada al
público porque de los 5.000 cuadros del
museo tan solo la mitad de ellos están
expuestos
el objetivo es hacer vivir un poco la
colección no mostrar siempre las mismas
obras así cuando un visitante regresa al
museo tras uno dos o tres meses siempre
hay algo nuevo por ver una nueva obra
que sale de las reservas eso sí debe ser
[Música]
[Aplausos]
más allá de las salas de exposición o
las reservas las obras también viajan
regularmente tal como está empacada y
que acaba de llegar de turín
el cuadro es manipulado con minucia
se trata de una obra maestra del
impresionismo la catedral de jun de
claude monet
la misión del conservador es delicada
hay que garantizar que la obra no haya
sido dañada durante el transporte con la
catedral de monet se trata de un
ejercicio muy agradable porque uno se
sumerge en la materia y cuando más cerca
estamos del cuadro más se ve el trabajo
del pintor moneo
la acumulación de los trazos el juego de
los matices y se tienen una especie de
mirada abstracta del color bastante
embriagador
regreso a la sala de exposición con la
restauradora alix la voz
a quien se apresta a realizar la última
operación
y protegemos la cabina los muros porque
tendremos que pulverizar el esmalte y
caerá por todas partes entonces
protegemos al máximo
el rescate del remordimiento de badr
llega a su fin
al islám o cubre la obra con una resina
natural que debe ser aplicada de manera
homogénea
el gesto es preciso y el resultado
inmediato
estábamos trabajando algo que tenía
tendencia a volverse amarillento y el
esmalte que aplicamos permite
rejuvenecer finalmente tal como decía
una crema hidratante no es falso ello
alimenta la superficie y le permite al
color retomar su profundidad
la obra abandona su jaula de vidrio para
reunirse con el público
la catedral de jun también retomará su
lugar en la sala monet
[Música]
el pintor presentó el monumento en cinco
versiones a diferentes horas del día
el conservador las ubica en función de
la luz
sale el sol hay una especie de bruma de
la mañana se avanza y el sol está más
presente y los contrastes son más
visibles
en el museo de orsay se hace todo para
impactar a los visitantes sin importar
su edad
daley y bobby es artista plástica y
anima talleres para niños varias veces
al mes
ghoga no es coqueto gogh paul gauguin el
tema del día pintar la selva como la de
one miramos el primero hay algo que
salta a la vista en este cuadro han
visto perros naranjas
es esto lo que es particular en su
pintura es que pinta las cosas
inventando colores como si se tratara un
poco de colores de ensueño vamos al
taller
dirección el taller para pasar de la
teoría a la práctica
y me gustan mucho estas plantas son muy
bellas
pintar permite agudizar la curiosidad de
los niños y por qué no decorar las
paredes de la sala